foreign
today's question comes from Jeremy in
Colorado I'm a big fan of your show and
love the videos I'm married and we have
a one-year-old daughter I've been
renting but I'm contemplating purchasing
a house my gross-based salary is 243 000
take-home pay after 401k and insurance
is eleven thousand dollars a month we
are paying 2200 in rents so my question
is how do we know when we're ready to
buy a house and how much money do I need
to buy I'm thinking I'm trying to think
through the down payment and the
mortgage payments but I know there are
other expenses during the buying process
and monthly that I'm not thinking
through and I want to be prepared
um great question Jeremy so when it
comes to owning a home and buying a home
we always tell people to be completely
debt free
and have three to six months of expenses
saved in the bank and then you're gonna
move on to what's called baby step 3B
so what you're gonna do Jeremy is figure
out okay we're gonna try to get at least
at five percent down payment ideally
more than that 20 would be incredible
because you could avoid PMI and other
types of insurance and these fees that
you're asking about later but we would
recommend at least you know five ten
percent down and your monthly mortgage
payment being no more than 25 of your
take-home pay so
it'll be kind of around what you're
paying for your rents right now honestly
is what it'll end up being well no
because the your take it says take-home
pay is 11 000 after 401K in Insurance 25
of your take-home pay not counting 401K
insurance it's just after taxes oh after
tax that's true yes and you're making
243 000. that's 20 000 bucks a month
so your take home pays not eleven
thousand you know your take on pay
you're counting foreign
it's probably more like 15. and so a
fourth of your take-home pay not
counting insurance and taxes with a
properly withheld tax amount all we want
to take out is taxes okay and then 25 of
that number so you make a lot of money
you're going to be fine uh you you know
you need to decide if you want to stop
your 401k temporarily to be able to save
even more and build that down payment up
but uh that's baby step 3B it's okay to
stop that for a little bit but that 25
take-home pay formula does include like
HOA fees Insurance all of that yeah
principal interest taxes insurance and
HOA okay
um and because that's the cost of owning
the house uh it not your electric bill
not your water bill that kind of stuff
and so uh but it's just what we're
trying to do is not have you be house
poor where your house payment is a huge
percentage of your take-home pay but in
your case you probably can go to a three
to a four thousand dollar house payment
without any trouble uh you're going to
be right in you're still going to be
right in there and um probably four uh
maybe maybe between thirty five hundred
and four but somewhere right in there
and that's on a 15-year fixed rate with
as big a down payment as you can scrape
up before you make the purchase now
we've got a great blog on real estate
how much money do I need to buy a house
and it's in great detail some of the
stuff we just covered uh at
ramseysolutions.com we will put the link
in the show notes for those of you on
podcast and in the description for those
of you on YouTube and so you'll be able
to pull that link up on and reiterate
what you know am I ready to buy a house
because everyone's running around right
now like a chicken with their head cut
off if you don't know what that is
you'll learn it from your country
grandmother but if everybody's running
around like crazy right now thinking I
gotta buy a house got to buy house Gotta
Buy house gotta buy a house Gotta Buy
house if I don't buy a house if I don't
buy okay you know it's always been that
way I've been doing the show for 30
years there's always been people with
house fever
and they lose their minds and they go
with a big old debt they got big old car
payment
they got student loans coming out their
ears and then they go buy a house and
they're broke
and they can't figure out why the
purchase of a home was not a blessing
it's because you bought a house when
you're broke
that's why
you know you shouldn't do that so we are
you know Ramsey you're just too
conservative now we're just using some
freaking common sense a little bit of
restraint
in a culture where no one ever tells
anyone no for anything
no you shouldn't buy a house you're
broke get yourself where you ain't broke
and then you buy a house and then it
won't be harmful to you it'll be a
blessing it doesn't affect me I don't
care if you do it or not but if you're
asking me how I can be a blessing to you
how I can make your life better we're
here to tell you that and that's what
we've done how much money do I need to
buy a house it's a great blog at
ramseysolutions.com in the show notes or
in the description on YouTube don't miss
that and Jeremy you ought to go read
that too